nous sommes dans l'opposition
dans l'opposition au gouvernement et à
emmanuel macron nous avons combattu
pendant ces élections législatives et
nous resterons bien évidemment sur cette
ligne donc il n'est pas question ni de
pacte ni des coalitions ni quelques
accords de quelque nature que ce soit en
revanche nous conduirons comme nous
l'avons toujours faire nos positions
responsables c'est à dire en étant force
de proposition sur chacun des textes qui
seront proposés et nous présenterons
soit avant la fin de l'été soit soit à
l'automne une série de propositions sur
les différents sujets qui sont les
sujets de préoccupation des français au
quotidien que ce soit sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur la sur la sécurité sur la
sur la santé sur sur l'immigration sur
l'éducation nationale